we begin in washington where a late
night attempt to delay the vote on
president biden's spending plan ended
just hours ago overnight republican
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
spoke for eight and a half hours but
despite his efforts the vote will likely
go forward this morning on a measure
that covers everything from the cost of
child care to the fight against climate
change nicole killian reports from
capitol hill
with that madam speaker i yield back
house minority leader kevin mccarthy
used a procedure called a magic minute
that turned into more than eight hours
on the house floor no there's a record
there's a record
i'm competitive to stall democrats from
passing their massive social spending
plan this is the single most reckless
and irresponsible spending bill in our
nation's history amen
it's all right i got all night
[Applause]
despite some dozing and heckling
lawmakers nobody elected joe biden to be
fdr
democrats remain poised to pass the 1.75
trillion dollar package which includes
free universal pre-k and an extension of
the child tax credit new investments in
climate housing health care and up to
four weeks of paid leave this is
historic
it is transformative
and will help us build back better with
women and all those who had not
previously had the full advantage
leader mccarthy broke speaker pelosi's
record for holding the floor and while
democrats may be clearing one hurdle
they will face more when this bill goes
to the senate including from some in
their own party but majority leader
chuck schumer told me he hopes to get
this done by christmas gail
all right nicole thank you